as we begin to wrap up 2019 we're
treated to a blockbuster of a full
season sequels from any popular anime
series as well as the new Smash Hits
line the latter half of 2019 this she
also saw the birth of another successor
to the mainstream Shonen anime lines
after the rise of my hero academia a
couple of years ago however let's save
the sentimentality of 2019 for when the
years about to end for now we'll take a
look at tomorrow if you think the 2019
says star-studded year for anime you
ain't seen nothing yet
starting the list of anticipated
twenty20 shows at number 10 is our easy
row second season 2016 saw the release
of the smash he is Sakai rezero breaking
off the traditional mold of overpowered
heroes it bought a more realistic take
on the genre was giving the protagonist
subaru the unique ability of having a
reset button now thanks to these Subarus
and misadventures in another world and
his quest of becoming the greatest hero
for the girl of his dreams has gone at
much praise and acclaim the last time we
saw the Subaru succeed in his quest as
Amelia and Subaru spend a touching
moment on the field at the close of
season one it seems after much suffering
things are finally looking up for our
unfortunate hero little did he know
though that the real battle is only
about to begin
rezero fans rejoice as the much awaited
second seasons here Ram fans at least
you'll finally get the jokes and memes
that have been floating around on the
internet for years
[Music]
not to be confused by a jumpsuit wearing
ninja buzu maki is another popular work
from horror maestro's Yuji Ito I'm
surprised it took this long for it to
get an anime production but here we are
looking at an assumed Aki anime this
2020 strange happenings take place in
Carrozza Cho such as suicide people
transforming into snails and other
oddities turns out that the source
behind this is a curse involving spirals
a high school teenager and her boyfriend
witnessed this curse firsthand and
they'll soon find that ending the curse
is more complicated than it seems it
took a long time didn't it while a zoo
monkey had a live-action film in 2000 I
didn't expect them to take this long to
produce an anime series for the popular
manga horror aficionados it looks like I
have something for you to look forward
to this coming year Noel ranked 8th
anime is kind of a nostalgic familiar
face especially to older fans yes it's a
new ghost in the shell' anime as
announced last year netflix are
producing a new ghost in the shell'
anime for 2020 now not much has been
revealed apart from that standalone
complexes director is coming back to
direct
it's got to be pleasing for longtime
fans of the sci-fi series to know that a
new anime is coming next year as one of
the most popular cyberpunk series it's
been adapted into numerous shorts games
and movies including a Hollywood one as
well for those not familiar with the
source material it's set in a world with
blurred lines between humanity and
technology and follows Kusanagi of
Japan's counter terrorist organization
Public Security section 9 it's not too
late to get up to speed with this
interesting series to start reading or
watching now and that way you could join
the hype in 2020
at 7:00 we take a look at season 4 of
high q-- sports animes are a dime a
dozen but I'm sure that few have reached
the longevity that haikyuu has when it
comes to getting season renewals I'm
sure that high Q fans are more than
stoked to see a continuation of the
manga adaptation and things look to be
heating up on the road to Nationals
manga readers prepared to see training
camp and the Tokyo matches adapted in
anime form the currently released
visuals already have people talking and
I'm sure they'll be greeted with the
stream of nice surprises as we get
closer to crunch time the content this
season isn't likely to reach Nationals
matches but with a series as popular as
high Q they can't just leave us hanging
like that now can they
I expect a follow-up season to be
announced straight after this and with
that we can expect a lot more sports
goodness to follow the best news is is
that we don't have to wait long
high Q to the top launches in January
another case study that cover but does
the turf-cutter sewage disposal
it's been a while since I've seen one of
these shows Dora hey duros a sane
n-series set in a dystopian world known
as the whole here sorcerers exist in
another realm and typically enter the
whole to perform magical experiments on
hapless victims our protagonist Chi Minh
is one such victim after tasting a
sorcerers magic he's left with the head
of a Chi Minh and lost memories
accompanied by a girl he hunts magic
users to further his quest to regain
those lost memories I'm surprised this
anime got greenlit despite the manga
ending a year ago after almost 18 years
of serialization with its combination of
gore fanservice and black humor it has
gone a quite a fanbase it will start
airing in January
[Music]
and thus another trilogy comes to a
close fate/stay night heavens feel is
having its third and final movie in 2020
titled a spring song with the true
nature of fuyuki city shadow revealed
last movie shiro and ren move on to
their final confrontation with barely
anyone left to turn to for help they
seek help from a suspicious man who in
actuality has far deeper ties to their
bloodlines than they think
faced with the toughest decision that
can change the course of history
what will our idealistic hero choose the
world or Sakura in addition to
witnessing Ryder's time to shine we'll
finally see the decisive clash against
shadow Sakura and saber alter after much
build-up from the first two movies
heavens field looks to be heading
towards an exciting climax demon Slayers
movie takes the 4th spot on our list I
didn't see this coming to be honest not
the movie but how demon slayer suddenly
became a household name in the anime
world injustice snap when it started out
it seemed to be typical shown unfair yes
it had its fans and yes a compelling
plot supported by the nice music and
interesting characters making it one of
the best shows to watch in 2019 however
at least to me anyway it was never gonna
reach the heights that its genre
contemporary my hero academia did in
terms of popularity all it took was good
old youfo table magic and in a flash
demon slayer became a storm that surged
all over the anime community lo and
behold we have a movie on its way
imagine if they start adapting more
shown in series I for one hope they
really do anyway this movie chronicles
the short demon train ugh featuring a
tale of dreams and highlights the battle
between ren goku and Icaza
in third we have the promised
Netherlands second season the promise
Neverland somewhat of a surprise here it
was no surprise that shounen jump dark
tail on survival horror became really
popular but I didn't expect to see a
second season on its way after watching
the first one after all while the first
season wrapped up with an open-ended
ending the feeling of victory after the
children finally escaped the farm of
death known as grace Fieldhouse lent
itself to an already satisfying
conclusion for the series nevertheless
questions remain as to what's in store
for Emma ray and the rest of the
children in life outside the deathtrap
surely the demons they barely escaped
won't be thwarted so easily I sense more
action and battles coming in this second
season what other perils await the
children in the world beyond grace
Fieldhouse we'll find out in 2020
crashing in at the number two spot is
Evangelion 3.0 plus 1.0 they sure kept
us waiting didn't they
after short waits in between the first
three movies the fourth and final
Evangelion films coming after eight
years of waiting despite the troubled
production and multiple delays looks
like things are finally under way for
the conclusion of the rebuild of
evangelion so far the movie series has
given us a nice reboot and restructuring
of the legendary series with the first
three movies enjoying praise and acclaim
from fans and critics the fourth looks
to wrap everything up nicely with a
completely new conclusion to the entire
series Japanese fans from all walks of
life can't wait to see how it all ends
in the film series and nor can we better
late than never really at long last
we'll finally see how rebuild of
evangelion concludes whether it'll match
up to end of evangelion will be up for
debate regardless one thing's for sure
it should be a glorious finish we finish
off this list with one of the most hyped
series of 2020 attack on titans 4th
season what else did you expect but
arguably the biggest hit in the world of
anime as far as the last decades
concerned taking on the momentum of its
explosion into the anime scene at the
first half of the decade attack on titan
looks to finish things off in style with
three seasons of emotional roller
coasters in tow the epic the tales of
humanity's battle against monstrous
Titans will see its end this coming year
action drama thriller Spence leaked
animation and an intricate plot full of
twists attack on titan has it all will
we finally get to the bottom of the
mystery surrounding the Titans will
everyone make you out alive let's cross
our fingers and hope we get satisfying
answers to those questions as someone
who's caught up with the manga I'll bet
this could be the best season yet
right now the manga sand is pink and
that's why it's it's top of this list
one thing's for sure we'll all be in for
one hell of a thrilling ride it all
comes to an end in fall 2020 that wraps
up this list then at first class 2020 is
already shaping up to be a year of
blockbusters and epic conclusions as we
progress through the year I'm sure that
more exciting anime announcements will
keep popping up now let me ask you
something
which
titles are you most excited about I'd
love to hear your thoughts and make sure
to let them be heard through the
comments section make sure to also leave
a like and subscribe as we plan to have
more content on 2020 anime as the year
approaches well that does it for now see
you next time on vide tube
[Music]